Vitamin C, infusions are going well in northern Minnesota,
so this person is from northern Minnesota,
it's fantastic very able to get that out at MD,
Willie also, Willie to prescribe low dose,
Deltruxone, that is great.
Once again, dose seed, opinion, desired if I have to
can since arrival to this program,
I've had gastric pegged tube placed due to
suing starvation, distal, esophageal issues.
I cannot give you dosage on low dose,
Deltruxone, since that is a prescription medication.
I can't tell you what is pretty standard.
Low dose, no, Deltruxone, Deltruxone was actually
is a drug that is prescribed to help people get off of,
I think like more feeding things, like addictions,
but it's it's prescribed in like 50 milligram dosage for that.
That's why it's called low dose, Deltruxone,
because some brave doctor found that given Deltruxone
at a very low dose, that is 1.5 milligrams
and then titrated up to 4.5 milligrams before bed
can be a very good, I mean, regulator,
so it's so your immune cells are, you have immune
stimulating cells, you have immune suppressing cells,
and I should say, different chemicals in your body
that will stimulate an immune response, different chemicals in your body
that will call an immune response or cause decreased inflammation.
And then you have what are called T-regulator cells,
T-regulator cells help balance your immune system.
So in a case of somebody with a hyperactive immune system,
no, that would be typically somebody with brain trauma,
somebody with neurodegenerative diseases,
somebody with autoimmune disease.
So an autoimmune disease is when it's in a layered situation,
you have this hyperimmune response where a lot of inflammatory chemicals
called cytokines are being secreted.
So you've got this hyper inflammatory response going on
and that is really what can cause a lot of the symptoms
in people that have an autoimmune disease
in its layered condition.
So let's use an example and say a rheumatoid arthritis,
and my rheumatoid arthritis is really flared up my hands
they're just really, really hurting
and it's just very inflamed and red and it's very painful.
Well, that is because you're getting this hyper release of these inflammatory cytokines.
What part of your immune system balances that
is what are called your T-reg cells.
That's short for T-regulator cells.
So T-regs help balance a hyperimmune system.
They also have balance a hypoimmune system.
It has been found that low dose naltrexone can be
can be another exogenous T-reg stimulator.
So it stimulates your T-reg cells so that it can help balance that.
So people with autoimmune disease,
some of people have been helped by taking low dose naltrexone.
It could help calm down that inflammatory process.
It's been shown to be possibly helpful with people with inflammatory
disorders in the brain too.
It could be helpful.
Now there's been some speculation of using it with people with cancer
because sometimes being with cancer have a very
suppressed immune system of them using low dose naltrexone can help
acting as a T-regulator help bring that up.
So that is really the use of low dose naltrexone.
Typically the dose is started at 1.5 milligrams,
taken before bed.
And then that's well tolerated.
You go up to three milligrams and up to 4.5 milligrams.
That's very well detailed in the literature.
So give me the recommendation to say what is out there in the literature.